okay Instagram Instagram hello my name
is cat Holmes I'm the author of mismatch
and a director of user experience design
at Google here are 10 things you may not
know about me
[Music]
get way outside of my comfort zone and
interact with other people making
something that we ourselves can see it
matches how we learn but then it ends up
maybe excluding a much broader group of
people time energy money going into
something that nobody wants and nobody
uses my dream project to design would be
a playground and reading a story in that
kind of a play space conversation with
my kids no matter where I am in the
world taking the time to check in and
just hear about their day you're not
alone in Seattle a growing practice to
throw axes as a way to relax turns out
I'm pretty good at it my headphones
throwing in some music just to change my
brainwaves for a minute I'd be a
filmmaker I'm very much an introvert I
love being with large groups of people I
love talking about and sharing my work
but after doing that I have to go take a
really long nap
you